on the wild firefight in California it
is still continuing as you know crews
are battling a new fire that exploded
overnight in Ventura County
that's northwest of Los Angeles it grew
in just a few hours to more than eight
thousand acres more than 7,000 people
are under evacuation orders at this hour
the so-called Maria fire is just one of
many wildfires to erupt in California
during this period of dangerous fire
conditions those fires have burned more
than one hundred and one thousand acres
over 21 days Carter Evans is near
tsoumas the latest community to be
threatened Carter when will people there
get a break well it looks like they're
going to get a break later today we'll
talk about that in a second first I want
you to see these embers blowing behind
me this is how those spot fires get
started as those embers get thrown out
ahead of the flames you can see the
flames burning over here the good news
for firefighters the high winds that
have been fueling these flames really
across the state are expected to die
down later today
overnight the fast-moving berea fire
descended upon small agricultural
communities known for their citrus
orchards and avocado farms
hundreds of firefighters raced to
respond battling back flames as they
threatened to breach property lines but
aerial footage showed at least one
building ablaze around 1,800 structures
are under threat and roughly 7,500
people face evacuation orders we've got
access issues getting to the actual
edges of the fires Ventura County
officials warned the mountainous terrain
may make containing the fire a struggle
but assured the community it would not
see a repeat of 2017 s catastrophic
Thomas fire which engulfed more than
280,000 acres destroyed nearly 1,100
structures and resulted in two deaths
earlier this week Ventura County was
already facing the so-called easy fire
which is now 60 percent contained and
east of Los Angeles firefighters
yesterday made progress on the hillside
fire in this San Bernardino neighborhood
I was asleep
Matthew Valda vias home was one of at
least six destroyed by flames
everything was just glowing and flames
in the back of the house I just woke up
my wife and I told her hey get the kids
get in the car now there are some
firefighters not too far from where we
are but they seem to be pretty
comfortable letting this debris pile
burn itself out and they also seemed
very confident that this fire will burn
a maximum of 12,000 acres it's an 8,000
right now the reason they believe 12,000
is because of the direction the fire is
burning
it's simply gonna run out of vegetation
Tony
terrifying to imagine waking up with a
fire in your backyard Carter Evans
Forrest Carter thank you very much